The one thing that you do need to pay
attention, to ,with touch on mobile, is the click delay.
Touch supporting mobile browsers, usually interpret double tapping, as
a zoom into this element gesture. Unfortunately, this means the
platform, delays finds click of it until it can
decide whether, the user is double tapping, about a third
of a second, chrome has recently checked in some changes,
that minimize this behavior. But, pretty much, all mobile browsers,
have this click delay feature, to some degree. There are
a few ways to fix this problem, and, get clicks
without a delay, you can set the view port, to
be non-scalable. Either, set user scalable, to no, or set minimum
scale and maximum scale, to one, which has the same
effect. This can cause accessibility problems, though, so be careful jumping,
to this solution. You need to make sure, if you
do this, that your site will never ,need to be zoomed.
You can use a fast click library, like the ft labs one, that we've linked
down below. But ,you do have to
be careful, about how this impacts, your scrolling
performance, be sure to read the directions,
very carefully. Where finally, of course, you can
implement tech support yourself directly, if you consume
the touch events, you won't have this issue.